now with us is the president's attorney
former New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
mr. mayor great to see you and heard a
lot of news let's get your reaction to
congressman meadows jordan and more
importantly the fourth well the third
renewal the fourth FISA warrant rod
Rosenstein signed off on rob Rosen's
it's one people in charge of this case
so I'm not gonna get involved in
critiquing his conduct unless at the end
we have to I'm hopeful he's gonna make
the right decision I see the case
falling apart I see in front of my eyes
what happened yesterday
with the first of Cohen's tape what
happened today was the one with Chris
Cuomo which is not Cuomo's fault it's
his fault that one I mean they've been
saying all along did the president know
about it Cohen says on the tape he
didn't know about it
did Cohen pay for Cohen said he paid for
it was it for the campaign or with a
personal Cohen says it was personal over
and over again not just what is it you
our tape and and and Cuomo like a report
of president and he sticks with his
story why really totally with regard to
that particular situation once again
totally legitimate conduct from what we
read of this this was a two-hour
conversation but let's go back to last
time for just a second and you will
listen to that tape how many times in
some say it's a check and you say that
the president said check the president
said I have it right here I have the
transcript I had five people go over it
and then another five you got it listen
to it four or five times which is when I
talked about mafia tapes let's talk
about this being a mafia tape I said I'm
an expert on tapes I did 4,000 hours of
men on tape then put you the next movie
Donald Trump says don't pay with cash
interruption Cohen no no no no I got it
check no no no and then very very
suspiciously he cuts the tape off
because it's a very very innocent very
solid explanation here's another reason
how to be checked before they talk about
doing it by corporation how they can I
do cash to a corporation budget of $50
in possible might as well sign up for
jail yeah let's look at the big picture
let's the status this has gone on look
at the country it's so divided
I've been very harsh in terms of I
believe that a presidential election at
the highest levels that the fix was in
that Hillary was guilty of obstruction
and violating the Espionage Act and it
was rigged I believe what we learned
about the FISA warrants on Saturday
night they never verified the
information they never corroborated the
information they purposely withheld from
the judges on four separate occasions
that this was Hillary Clinton bought and
paid for what turned out to be Russian
lies there's a Russian conspiracy here
there's a Russian influence if you look
at theoretically they're one of the
things that concerned about did the
president obstruct justice
when he fired comment first of all he
has a right to do it in our article two
secondly he made it clear to Lester Holt
he did it knowing that the investigation
would continue so he couldn't have
obstructed it and 30 had about fifty
reasons for doing it including the
Horowitz report that kind of outlines
that a witness a is right on the other
hand how does Hillary not get prosecuted
for destroying tapes lying at least
three or four times having people have
any people tell totally phony stories
false expell Praetorian statements
destruction of evidence that's all
evidence of intent corrupt intent so
let's say well reads that all the way as
if it didn't exist
he told Laura last night excuse me I
don't you got me coma he got it he told
Laura Ingraham last night that there are
no more tapes on Donald Trump everyone's
reporting it as 12 tapes
avenatti was running around all weekend
saying he set it on ABC he actually said
he got it from Cohen and he said on TV
Dershowitz cross-examined him
brilliantly and got him to say he got
the tapes from Cohen and there were
there were numerous tapes with
presidents Ron well the government must
be hiding them if that's the case and I
sure I assure you the Southern District
of New York is not hiding evidence in
fact I can't imagine some of the best
prosecutors came out of there I said
imagine that's I can't imagine am i
shocked by this unbelievable assault on
the attorney-client privilege my god I
never heard of this America has been
following this and I've been given a
very different narrative that is really
everything we've reported has come true
I wish some of it was wrong by the way
and I still say that the heroes in this
gonna be FBI and CIA guys my question to
you is is this now coming to an end
because you talked last night and I
watched Alan Dershowitz after that there
won't be any talk about obstruction with
the president there then is there going
to be a subpoena fight is there going to
be any discussion about collusion and
why would you ever allow him to talk to
this group of people which I have very
strongly criticized well it certainly is
a big barrier there's no reason to talk
about obstruction because article 2
precludes obstruction the defenses to
obstruction are overwhelming including
what I told you his saying he knew the
can't the investigation would go on to
less to hold they conveniently leave
that off whenever they play that tape
amazing what they do with tapes however
there is a narrow area where Jay and I
both think that we might think about it
and we're in discussions with the with
the special counsel about it it would
all have to do with collusion so there's
no perjury trap it would all be done so
we get this thing over with why do I not
believe that they could do without
setting a perjury trap I just well then
then they'll give up on the obstruction
point where there's no obstruction case
and what they're trying to set up as the
president against Comey and they're
gonna believe call me no matter the fact
that Comey is probably one of the most
incredible guys around well let's be
done before the election I believe it
will I think I think mama wants to get
it over before the election I really
believe that good for the country yeah
you think he's a good man I think he's
okay I think he's a good man I think
he's got some people around him that
including one with a record that's
astounding me back I don't know when
you're talking about you sorry mr. mayor
great to see you as always thank you